hallo leute in unserer episode heute
möchten wir euch drei sendungen
empfehlen die ihr gucken könnt mit
deutschen untertiteln
immer wieder fragt die uns was können
wir gucken wenn wir deutsch lernen
wollen und das ist tatsächlich gar nicht
so einfach bei easy german machen wir
sehr präzise und till damit ihr wirklich
jedes wort und jede cell lesen könnt und
das ist sehr wichtig zu verstehen
aber wenn man sich einen fx serie oder
ein kinofilm oder eine fernsehserie
anguckt und dann die untertitel
einschaltet dann sind die nicht immer
präzise denn vielleicht sind dafür
gemacht dass leute nur den inhalt
verstehen und nicht unbedingt dass sie
eins zu eins transkribiert sind und
deshalb haben wir heute drei tipps für
euch die ihr gucken könnt mit relativ
guten untertiteln
die erste sendung die ich euch empfehlen
möchte heißt titel thesen temperamente
und sie ist meine lieblingssendung im
deutschen fernsehen ich gucke sie sehr
gerne denn es geht um kunst kultur und
politik es gibt immer fünf bis sechs
minütige beiträge zum beispiel über ein
neues buch einen film oder über ein
künstler und das ganze hat auch ziemlich
präzise deutsche untertitel
je nach beitrag ist natürlich das
vokabular ein bisschen höher oder ein
bisschen schwieriger zu verstehen aber
ich glaube dass es ganz interessant ist
um auch zu sehen welche themen sind in
deutschland politisch interessant oder
relevant hier unten poste ich den link
zu dieser sendung und es kann sein dass
dieser link nicht in allen ländern
funktioniert denn er ist vielleicht in
anderen ländern gesperrt in diesem fall
müsst ihr gucken wie ihr vielleicht ja
das so macht dass es aussieht als würde
dir aber eine deutsche ip adresse dieses
angebot schauen vielleicht kann ein paar
andere von euch hier mal einen tipp oder
einen link posten wie man das machen
kann
meine zeit empfehlung ist ein youtube
kanal namens germania und auf diesem
youtube kanal gibt es jede woche eine
neue episode und in dieser episode wird
ein mensch aus deutschland mit einem
migrationshintergrund vorgestellt das
heißt eine person die entweder selbst
nicht in deutschland geboren ist oder
deren eltern aus einem anderen land
eingewandert sind und ich finde dieses
projekt sehr interessant denn es zeigt
die vielfalt deutschlands aber auch die
vielfalt in diesen verschiedenen gruppen
ganz oft geht es ja in der politischen
debatte immer um deutsche und um
ausländer und das ist denke ich viel zu
kurz gegriffen denn es ist natürlich ein
großer unterschied ob jemand aus polen
kommt oder aus tunesien oder ob jemand
freiwillig nach deutschland gekommen ist
oder nicht freiwillig ob er hier mit
seiner familie seit generationen lebt
oder alleine und ich finde es wirklich
sehr spannend
das ganze ist auch interessant für euch
zum verstehen die unter sind ungefähr
90% präzise denke ich also nicht ganz
präzise aber dadurch dass die episoden
sehr kurz sind und auch immer nur einen
sprecher haben ist es sehr gut
nachvollziehbar und gleichzeitig geht es
immer um diese fragen von familie
identität heimat also auch ein gutes
zugängliches vokabular schaut mal rein
der link ist hier unten meine dritte
empfehlung für euch ist das leck tief
das ist ein youtube kanal und auf dem
werden jede woche reportagen meistens
aus deutschland veröffentlicht diese
reportagen sind immer so 15 bis 25
minuten lang und sie sind komplett
untertitel und bei den reportagen geht
es darum verschiedene lebensstile
vorzustellen also menschen die einen
besonderen beruf haben oder mit einer
krankheit leben oder die auf eine
besondere art und weise
da könnt ihr zum beispiel sehen wie
sieht der alltag eines polizisten in
deutschland aus oder der alltag eines
obdachlosen zwei themen die ich
interessant fand waren sendungen in
denen das leben von politische radikalen
vorgestellt wurde zum beispiel ein
ehemaliger neonazi und eine gruppe
linksradikaler wirklich sehr spannende
themen die auch zeigen wie deutschland
aussieht
in diesem in diesem zeitalter und guckt
euch das mal an und schaut euch die
reportagen an auch den link gibt es hier
unten
ja das waren unsere drei empfehlungen
guckt sie euch mal an und ich würde mich
auch sehr freuen wenn ihr einen
kommentar da last ob ihr dieses diese
drei sendungen interessant findet ob sie
hilfreich furchtbaren und natürlich
möchten wir auch eure tipps hören was
guckt ihr wenn ihr deutsche serien oder
filme oder sendungen gucken wollte
postet eure kommentare hier unten und
vielleicht können wir dann eine ganz
interessante linksammlung für euch
zusammen stellen
hier könnt ihr ein mitglied werden von
easy german bei patchen bekommt ihr jede
woche übungen transkripte vokabel listen
und hier könnt ihr uns abonnieren
wir freuen uns wenn ihr auch nächste
woche wieder einschaltet